technologie ist im grunde genommen
nichts anderes als dass um ordnen von
atomen in einer art und weise die für
uns nützlich ist ob wir vor
zehntausenden von jahren aus einem stein
eine pfeilspitze geformt haben oder ob
wir heute aluminium stampfen und
schweißen um daraus eine rakete zu bauen
welches material welche eigenschaften
hat wird dabei auf der atomaren ebene
entschieden kupfer hält zum beispiel
seine form weil die atome aus denen das
kupfer besteht in einem regelmäßigen
muster angeordnet sind
wir können das allerdings verformen wenn
wir mit einem hammer darauf schlagen
weil die einzelnen lagen übereinander
gleiten können ohne dabei zu reißen
glas hingegen bricht sehr schnell weil
sich die einzelnen atome voneinander
lösen bevor sie rutschen gummi wiederum
besteht aus einem netzwerk aus
ineinander verdrehten molekülen die man
sich wie federn vorstellen kann wenn man
daran zieht dann strecken sich die
einzelnen moleküle und ziehen sich
danach wieder zusammen in den
ausgangszustand das ist die welt in der
wir heute leben mit unseren werkzeugen
können wir zwar materialien bieten
formen und verdrehen aber nicht immer
ändern welche eigenschaften das material
hat wir können meister in schleifen und
schneiden manipulieren dabei aber immer
viele atome auf einmal was wäre wenn wir
einzelne atome genau positionieren
könnten wie wir es uns vorstellen
wir könnten neuartige materialien
herstellen die widerstandsfähiger und
leichter sind als alle heute bekannten
materialien
wir könnten krankheiten besiegen und den
alterungsprozess aufhalten indem wir
unsere zellen auf der atomaren ebene
verändern
alles was in unserer heutigen welt nicht
richtig funktioniert kann man auf der
atomaren ebene korrigieren
wir könnten sogar noch weiter gehen und
kleine fabriken bauen die kleine roboter
herstellen die wiederum dafür da sind
noch andere roboter herzustellen
eine armee aus kleinen nano roboter mit
der wir die physische welt um uns herum
so verändern könnten wie wir es uns
vorstellen die rohstoffe dafür atome
sind reichlich vorhanden
wir müssen sie nur neu anordnen
[Musik]
das wort nano kommt aus dem
altgriechischen und bedeutet zwerg ein
nanometer ist ein milliardstel meter um
euch davon eine vorstellung zu geben
wenn die erde einen meter groß wäre dann
wäre ein nanometer so groß wie ein
fußball in der name technologie befasst
man sich mit strukturen die sich im
bereich zwischen einem und 1 100
nanometern bewegen das ist der bereich
in dem sich einzelne moleküle und atome
befinden
hier werden die eigenschaften eines
objekts vor allem durch die größe des
teilchens bestimmt da hier die
oberfläche eines objekts eine größere
rolle spielt als sein volumen mit
anderen worten nanowissenschaft ist ein
sehr komplexer und tief reichende
bereich und aus diesem grund habe ich
mich mit einem experten zusammengesetzt
der sich da genau auskennt torben
schindler ist molekularer nahmen
wissenschaftler und reist aktuell mit
dem innotrek quer durch deutschland wenn
man ihn auf die vielen unglaublichen
möglichkeiten an spricht über die ich
vor dem intro gesprochen habe
dann reagiert er erst einmal ein wenig
vorsichtig dass man immer stärker dann
einfluss nehmen kann vielleicht in der
zukunft irgendwann einmal dass man
wirklich mit solchen namen oder autos
auch durch den menschlichen körper
fahren kann aber ich glaube davon sind
wir noch sehr weit entfernt
aber was ist denn heute schon mit
nanotechnologie möglich im bereich der
medizin untersucht man aktuell ob man
mit hilfe von eisenoxid nanopartikeln
krebszellen zerstören kann
mit einem magnetfeld lassen sich diese
partikel nämlich erhitzen
der vorteil im vergleich zu älteren
methoden der krebsbehandlung ist dass
man die nano-partikel gezielt in den
krebszellen anreichern kann so dass bei
der behandlung weniger gesunde zellen
beschädigt werden
forscher arbeiten außerdem daran
nanokapseln zu entwickeln die
medikamente im körper zuerst an die
richtige stelle bringen bevor sie diese
dort freisetzen krebsmedikamente können
äußerst toxisch sein und sollten nicht
mit gesunden körperzellen in kontakt
kommen die mechanisierte nanokapseln
öffnet sich deswegen erst bei einer
veränderung des ph-wertes
nanotechnologie wird heutzutage auch
schon in alltäglichen produkten
angewandt zb im hochsicheren glas in
selbstheilenden materialien oder in
sonnencremes die mehr uv licht
absorbieren kann
viele wissenschaftler sehen in der
zukunft der name wissenschaft weniger
die ominösen nano roboter und vielmehr
die möglichkeit materialien neue
eigenschaften zu geben
auch das neuerdings beliebte material
graphen oder die kohlenstoff nanoröhren
fallen in den bereich der nano
wissenschaft
graphen besteht aus nur einer einzigen
lage kohlenstoff atome nanoröhren kann
man sich vorstellen wie einzelne graffin
lagen die aufgerollt wurden die
nanoröhren sind für ihr geringes gewicht
extrem widerstandsfähig und gleichzeitig
wunderbare strom und wärme leiter
zukünftige computerchips mit
transistoren auf basis dieser
materialien könnten taktraten von bis zu
1000 gigahertz erreichen das entspricht
ungefähr dem 200 fachen heutiger
verfügbarer siliziumchips vom energie
kraftwerk das wärme aus dem inneren der
erde heraus holt über das dunkelste uns
bisher bekannte material bis hin zum
weltraum aufzug scheint mit graffin und
kohlenstoff nanoröhren alles möglich man
kann außerdem bereits kleine molekulare
pumpen muskeln und schalter bauen sogar
molekulare motoren und darauf
basierenden ahnung autos gibt es schon
das funktioniert durch ineinander
gesteckte moleküle die wie die teile
einer kette miteinander verbunden sind
durch einen trick schafft man ist dass
sich das molekül nur in eine richtung
drehen kann
kombiniert man vier dieselmotoren über
ein gestell miteinander
dann erhält man ein kleines drei bis
vier nanometer großes nano auto und das
pferd dann wirklich mit sich mechanisch
drehen den rädern über eine oberfläche
den treibstoff für die fahrt zum
beispiel uv licht muss man gezielt von
außen zu führen unter anderem für diese
erfindungen haben mehrere forscher 2016
den chemie nobelpreis erhalten
aber wie baut man eigentlich etwas auf
der nanoskala heutzutage wird das über
chemische synthesen gemacht das können
22 stufige synthesen sein das heißt man
lässt zuerst zwei moleküle miteinander
reagieren oder zwei atom mit einem
molekül und dann geht man weiter dass
man schritt für schritt das ganze
aufwand das medium in dem das ganze
passiert ist beispielsweise wasser da
kann können auch alkohole sein also
unterschiedliche stoffe aber dann nimmt
man eine lösung von partikeln oder von
einzelnen
molekülen und gibt die dann zusammen so
dass es zu einer reaktion kommt also das
ist eine sehr sehr lange prozedur bis
man dann halt wirklich bei dem baustein
ist oder bei der maschine ist wie man
sich am ende vielleicht ausgedacht hat
und dass die dann halt auch entsprechend
eine funktion dann halt durch finden
kann
es ist ganz blöd gesagt was am ende
passiert ist dass man verschiedene
flüssigkeiten zusammen ja ja also genau
aber man muss halt aufpassen was für
flüssigkeiten und was für chemikalien
wandel und die sind dann sehr komplex
und dann kommt das noch dazu das
vielleicht nicht jede reaktion so
abläuft wir uns möchte dann muss man
nicht nur flüssigkeiten zusammen kippen
sondern man muss noch temperaturen
anlegen man muss vielleicht noch
katalysatoren dazu geben damit wirklich
diese reaktion so stattfindet wird
forscher der university of manchester
haben bereits einen programmierbaren
greifarm entwickelt mit dem sich
einzelne nanoteilchen präzise bewegen
lassen
ein erster schritt um maßgeschneiderte
moleküle und nano bauteile herzustellen
bis das in massenproduktion geschieht
und wie auch wirklich wissen wie wir
moleküle und nanomaschinen bauen die uns
etwas nützen wird es aber noch sehr
lange dauern dann aber können wir die
kleinen nano autos von vorhin um alle
möglichen funktionen erweitern es wären
kleine nano roboter oder kurz nano bots
ein möglicher weiterer schritt wäre ein
selbst replizieren bot der die atome in
seiner nähe verwendet um sich selber zu
vermehren und allerspätestens hier wird
sogar mir mulmig was man damit alles
anstellen könnte dass das militär an
einer solchen technologie interessiert
ist versteht sich von selbst kleinste
quasi unsichtbare roboter die uns mit
sensoren abhören in den körper
eindringen und bei bedarf vielleicht
sogar umbringen können
natürlich wird hier viel geld in die
forschung gesteckt aber es muss nicht
einmal so drastisch seien auch firmen
wie google facebook und amazon wären
bestimmt daran interessiert daten direkt
aus unseren körpern zu bekommen der
perfekte gläserne mensch aber auch hier
kann uns torben erst einmal beruhigen
wie wie soll eine
funktionen oder wie soll eine ein
datenabgleich erfolgen auch das ist
natürlich dann auch eine ganz ganz große
frage
wenn man jetzt an einen gläsernen
menschen denkt dass jetzt direkt dann
über nanotechnologie durchzusetzen bin
ich mir nicht so sicher wie das genau
funktionieren kann und auch die nano bot
selber sind aktuell noch eher fiction
als 21 wir sind da noch gar nicht so
weit dass wir alles das bauen können was
wir uns gerne ausdenken möchten also wir
brauchen da vor allem in der chemie ist
so dass wir dann halt immer schauen
müssen wo ist ein gleichgewichtszustand
wie können wir wirklich entsprechend
moleküle synthetisieren sind die
überhaupt stabil sind hier an luft
stabil
also da gibt es ganz ganz viele fragen
so dass dass es theoretisch unmöglich
ist erstmal sich sehr viel herzustellen
aber praktisch sind wir da noch ein
gutes stück weit von den partnern
roboter selber sind noch ein gutes stück
weit weg von der realität selbst
replizierende und kabellos
kommunizierende nano bots vielleicht
unmöglich
und trotzdem die vorstellung von
unsichtbaren und unkontrollierbaren
robotern ist angsteinflößend
deshalb gibt es einen eigenen
forschungsbereich die nano toxikologie
um gefahren im umgang mit nanostrukturen
zu erforschen
es ist also wie bei fast allen neuen
technologien die möglichkeiten scheinen
unendlich sowohl positiv als auch
negativ
jetzt liegt es an forschern wie torben
schindler diese möglichkeiten zu
erforschen und die positiven
entwicklungen umzusetzen
der innotec falls ihr es noch nicht
wisst zeigt zukunftstechnologien wie zum
beispiel kohlenstoff nanoröhren organe
aus dem 3d drucker oder virtual reality
und fährt jedes jahr 70 bis 80 stationen
in deutschland an vielen lieben dank an
torben schindler der mir als experte
gerade über eine stunde coole fragen
beantwortet hat vielen lieben dank auch
an das bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video und an euch vielen dank
fürs zuschauern bleibt neugierig
[Musik]